it's such a big eye I could bask in that
all night but it's such a big news day
and you know we're live live live now
like a lot of other shows who stay live
and they're not why we're live it's 700
or something on the west coast
I have breaking news okay the two
escaped murderers from New York the
prison right okay one's dead the one
they got the other surrounded which is
terrible timing for them because now
they can get married yes what a week are
the Confederate flags are coming down
and the rainbow flags are going up
which which made it a very weird week
for Lindsey Graham he is buried
but yes the Supreme Court did it today
they said marriage equality is the law
of the land in all 50 states the
definition of marriage has officially
shifted now from strictly between a man
and a woman to any two people who want
to get fat together that's the law and
of course there are the Republican
candidates for president are all against
this but they took the news with Grace
and goodwill I'm joking of course they
all went completely apeshit said crazy
things we will not honor any decision
rick santorum said which will force us
to violate our clear biblical
understanding mike huckabee said the
supreme court can't overrule god
Bobby Jindal said this ruling paves the
way for an all-out assault on religious
freedoms of Christians fellas you do
realize this is not mandatory okay you
don't have to have sex with another man
it's just an option now okay I just
wanted to make that clear
and the
yeah I sense drama queens
and the conservative bloc on the Supreme
Court all four of them all four wrote
dissenting opinions all in caps but you
know what the two women met Obama
appointed on the Supreme Court proved
the difference they calmly pointed out
that only marriage the marriage ruling
in this case is keeping with the ideals
of America but it sets a very good
example for Bristol Palin I'm not making
this up you heard about Bristol Palin
right man I usually go after the the
children of candidates but come on
Bristol who after she had the first baby
out of wedlock got paid to be an
abstinence spokesman and is now pregnant
with her second child out of wedlock I
mean this chick can see Russia from her
bed
instead of shooting wolves sarah palin's
you haven't raised her kids and and
Bristol is already already the mother to
Tripp and the nephew to Sara's kids trig
and track that's true
no no word yet on the name of the new
child but the earlier favourites are a
thud Clank and spank now this this was
not an easy week to be a conservative in
America not just Bristol Palin and gay
marriage Obamacare was confirmed by the
yeah Republicans were like if people can
marry and raise children and be well
what's to become a family values and the
Confederate flag is coming down
everywhere I mean
rush limbaugh's like boy I guess I
picked the wrong week to stop taking
oxycontin huh oh it's amazing how fast
that happened right after decades of all
these southerners defending this as a
symbol of the pride in our heritage no
it's racist gotta go
Republican governors are taking it down
from their state capitols everywhere and
the governors of Virginia North Carolina
and Tennessee called for banning this
Confederate flag on license plates this
is not sitting well with rednecks
they said they should be able to put any
type of license plate they want on their
house I kid the rednecks
no it's getting hard to have a
confederate flag anywhere Walmart Amazon
Sears eBay have all stopped selling all
Confederate flag merchandise they say
look it's just a matter of human decency
and they told their factories in China
to order their child slaves to stop
sewing